[Music]
okay so we have cassie david on the
podcast today kenzie
i almost don't want to say she's larry
david's daughter because that you just
said it
i did it but who cares everyone's
someone's daughter
yeah everyone she dated pete davidson
okay
like she's trying to get away from that
we i see pete davidson someone's
daughter
i i spent the entire time like bullying
her
into uh not being
letting her bullying letting herself
bully herself making herself blue
if it's just it's a wild it's a good
bully circle it's a it's a real
chinese finger anyone's going to bully
her it'll be you it's going to be me
with compliments yeah you say stop it
i'll handle this we have not been doing
open super consistently
and we are sorry for all of it
sorry let's do some new year's
resolutions ooh it's almost new year's
isn't that exciting what do you normally
do on new year's like in the past
comedy for like random like corporate
parties
oh do you talk to people there or do you
just do that and leave sometimes i'll do
like selfies it'll it's usually like a
weird hotel room
do you kiss them at midnight uh if is
that extra
that's part of the meet and greet
it's signed into the contract yeah it's
just kind of like okay like usually they
want
a comedy show then a kissing booth
usually they want me to like flick off
the camera or like
grab their boot wife's boobs or do a
thing
or and i'm always like can we just do a
photo corporate people are so crazy
they're wild
and they're drunk and it's in some weird
uh hotel room
uh out in kansas city missouri and it's
a bunch of rich people that
just don't really want to hear they
they're like roast me and i'm like you
don't want that
well that's fine i'm going to ruin your
marriage if i do that
have you done that we're in marriages at
corporate events i don't think
so also class extra maybe at the trump
roast
so many extras trump and melania i don't
think i ruined that marriage
um but i have some hardcore
new year's resolutions i want to focus
on
that are very specific i don't like
general
anything i'm going to eat healthier
that's not a you
that actually causes more anxiety
because you don't have a
goal to meet there's no way to prove
that you met your goal
and you're just panicking and worrying
and that causes stress you're always
going to fail
you're going to disappoint stress kills
you yes uh that's a generalization but
yes the release of cortisol
does degenerate collagen now which one
do you think people understood stress
skills or that
you're my subtitler you're my um what is
it um
sign language link to the outside world
um okay first new year's resolution for
me
i would like well this is for other
people
okay this is in whitney fashion these
are actually for you guys
these are notes on other people but i
would like to do they're always for me
because when something
bothers us about something else it's
usually uh
mirroring or showing us something about
ourselves we don't like
[Music]
that spooky also i don't know how true
that is but
it's very true i hope not it is
um i don't want
to ask someone a question that makes
them have to ask more questions back
a question should not give me work
so if you say hey want to get lunch
i have to go when where
what time i see i see complete cutting
out conversation
cut out the fat in the rigamar in the
back and forth
would you like to get lunch with me this
thursday at 2 p.m
at this location first in walnut then
they can tell you yes or no and there's
no
and that's two that's three texts
instead of 40. yeah and then you can
move on to something else
yes i'm giving you the gift of your
time i'm not going to steal your life
with my vague questions did you see that
clip
what clip send it email me the clip
i've emailed i've got so many clips
which clip
did you see that email which email out
of the 80 000.
so more specificity did you see the
email
from the sandy and marketing
about the blue hoodie yeah you just want
to be very
specific use your words complete
sentences
that's what you're wanting that seems
like an easy goal for everyone i'm
trying to train
all of our brains to do that so now you
guys have your resolution
you're welcome good thing you tuned in
um
wanna wanna talk when
right now nah that i've say now good
face time or like just be specific
just call you call you about blind call
vagueness is
the enemy of happiness i said it
vagueness is the enemy of happiness
being vague i could see how that would
i could see how that would work yeah
because then you don't know what you're
going for what you're looking for what
anyone's doing yeah
and you're thoughtful then you're just
making up your own facts you're just
you're guessing whatever turns into
assumptions oh i just assumed
why are you assuming you assumed
i just assumed literally i just assumed
you'd be like on your way home from work
how do you know when i got off work uh
find your phone
i'm tracking your location i know
honestly when the neural link
and the you know lex friedman um joe
rogan
all the elon musk when all the knurling
happens there you'll thank me later
that's my brand
you'll thank me later in trouble on
instagram
or the world wide web
because i over the uh the clip with
allison brie
yeah where she said uh
she didn't want to go to that uh she
went to that party and i was like don't
go to a party you don't want to go to
oh yeah and then she never was like
you're elitist
what was it uh i didn't read that but i
do know that
i don't have good manners yeah i mean
well you know i always go back and forth
about that i think that sometimes
self-care can lean into being selfish i
think that's what alison was saying
yeah like she did it because it's like
sometimes you do things to people you
love i think it's a case-by-case basis
and yeah it's not generalized because
that's my other new year's resolution
let's not generalize if it's a wedding
and someone spent money on you
get there if someone paid for that
plate you better show up but dragging
yourself across town to a party
that you don't want to go to when your
kid's sick and it's a hassle for you and
a hassle for them and you're gonna show
up and
bring your bad energy in and then resent
them later
yeah i love you so much please st don't
come to my party
i don't think people are there yet
that's why they didn't understand what
you were talking about
it's very much about like i think a lot
of people just like think you
you do things for people that you love
even if you don't want to do it
yeah but also it's very what's your
self-centered to be like
if i don't go to this party it'll be
ruined if i don't go to the party it'll
be the worst time you know i have to go
they're wanting me there well it's
the party it's not your party cancel it
without you yeah
that's what i'm saying so it's like both
sides are it's like no i know it's it i
was vague how about that
i was vague and vagueness is the enemy
right you were talking about something
you've already
mastered yeah and people we were not
don't understand words are in perfect
communication but that's okay and we
were generalizing
i think they get it now um and uh
oh don't uh my new year's resolution is
to not ask
people things that i can google
oh wow that's a most things
so hey she was just really cutting out
conversation in the new year you're just
not
her new actual resolution is not speak
to anyone she wants you to stop talking
to her and she would like to quit
talking to you
that's the real resolution i'm nell uh
no i just want to
go oh wanna eat at the farm grill
benton text me where's that
i could have googled that why did i just
create work for you
oh wow yeah you could have googled that
that is true
to be fair i wouldn't have been upset if
you asked i know but it's
it's it's we need to evolve past
creating work for the person that is
inviting us to do something do you think
everybody thinks that to work and that's
why that's
like you think that you feel like if
someone does that to you does it feel
like work
no a friend of mine a couple years ago i
didn't get it she was like um meet me at
the
hp marketplace and i was like where is
that and she wrote google it
and it like hurt my feelings
and then like two years later i was like
bitch you should have just fucking
googled it
yeah i could see yeah i could see both
sides why it hurt my feelings
but why why you're not uh jeeves
no one is now i think this i think
that's gone i don't think there is
anymore map quest
michael richards map quest you still
what do you still use this map class we
have to map quests everywhere we go just
by the way
more yeah and we print it off and put in
your your documents i like
a piece of paper we actually carry an
actual map around that
and we just and we take string and we
get each hotel and we just put the
points where we're going
mm-hmm i do carry a uh it's a fold-out i
do carry a
a calendar a paper calendar a desk
calendar
not like a travel calendar like a full
desk calendar notes on to cover
that is true that is true met with dr
david agus
the great dr david agus who is a guest
on our podcast went into his
gorgeous facility had to go into an
elevator alone because of covid
they had to let me in it was like this i
felt like i was going into like the
only kind of elevator i want to be in
alone pentagon
i go in i got my bloods my
panels my blood's taken and my panels
and my genetic everything
and uh he said you need to be going to
bed at the same time
every night and waking up at the same
time every morning that's my new goal
and that's when your resolution that is
a tough one that's probably the hardest
one you mean it doesn't matter what time
it is
just pick one 12 30 p.m to 7 30 fine
12 30 to 10 fine whatever it is 10
to 5 fine and just for general health or
is there a reason he told you like
yes uh because of your uh getting your
circadian rhythm in check i know
dr andrew huberman talks about this on
his instagram
uh page a bit just pick the time and
stick to it so that your body can get uh
delta and rem sleep huh that one sounds
very difficult i'll be honest that is a
piece of medical advice that i want to
give everyone for free
a saint a saint who can plan when
they're gonna go to bed i don't know
set an alarm to go to sleep there is one
there's
on your iphone you can do that and um he
we do the woot band
and but we also do the aura ring o-u-r-a
that's coming right
yes i'm getting the o-u-r-a ring which
tells you how you're sleeping
and if you have so much information on
your sleep i know if you have two
glasses of wine you're gonna be like
sleep worse when you wake up
if you have you know carbs at night is
that worse like just figure out what
works for
your body wow i'm excited to see if that
one
if you can do that that seems so
difficult do you think me making a um
[Music]
uh stop apologizing mandate to the women
that i work with
is bullying or abusing my mandate
i believe telling anyone to do anything
is kind of rude
well that i'm uh i have a problem
but like if we're getting a ring for
that too it'll tell you every time
yeah so like there's going to be a a
couple other women working here
next year if they apologize and they've
done nothing wrong what do i do
make them do 10 push-ups yeah that would
probably that would go over really well
i think i can see that now fantastic
yeah i would like you to stop i'm not
going to
we're different people and i get to do
this um
are we though i don't know what to do i
don't know
my gut is just you know i don't know i
don't know what would you
what would you do if i told you if you
apologized and i said stop apologizing
how would you feel um i think if i went
sorry and you just went
you did nothing wrong for what
it's a matter of rewiring our brains
it's just practice
it's like anything it's like it's like
uh when um
you you know you move to a new apartment
and you for the first
couple of months keep driving to the old
apartment when you're on your phone you
know you just automatically drive
the old it's like habit yeah yeah it's a
habit
what could you do i guess you should be
breaking a habit you know what pick the
emotion out of it you could take a
vacation day away each time they
apologize
every time you apologize you just take a
vacation day it's one day less you get
off
oh or oh give me a penny a dollar a
quarter in a jar
you're going to give them a dollar every
time i'll donate it that would be a
reason to apologize
like i'm oh you're gonna make them give
you a dollar yes
oh and then don't tell them but i'll
give it all back to them at the end of
the year
well they're gonna know now they don't
listen to my podcast
they're not great employees then so
let's rethink the whole situation here
um i also am as you've noticed
trying to uh develop a better
relationship with
music in terms of my mood
so i'm trying to always i got this
little necklace
uh if you're listening you can't see it
it's a necklace
broke it immediately broke it
literally my phone is on a necklace and
it is like a super helpful
and i play music that is nostalgic and
heartwarming
um to put me in a yummy mood positive
mood and i make playlists based on the
mood i want to be in
and that is a form of self-care yeah i
think i think that's
that's really i mean a lot of people do
that so i think you're catching up on
that one yeah
music guys have you heard me there's
only a whole tab on spotify
no but i'm just moving no but i'm saying
but i can't but no
er you are the only person that knows
the songs that make your power songs
you only know your power songs yeah
what's your like you're on a run
and like well this this theory didn't
work out because i'd never be on a run
so
i'm sitting on my couch what song am i
saying what's the song that's gonna put
you in a good mood
um go right now you're yelling i can't
think now
um if i write off the top of my head
right now i would probably play um
waiting for tonight
that's just what came in my head right
now like having that first thing in the
morning
playing it or anything off that new
miley cyrus album it's the best time
i've heard in years
really yeah every song great
great such a fan so this
she's like the wind
we're going to get coffee right on
youtube
okay sorry calum scott she's like the
wind it's a dirty dancing remix
like i don't love a rematch it's just a
it's just my song and i play it put it
on as soon as i wake up and it's
i'm very sensitive you know what other
song whitney loves that higher song with
whitney houston
that was an almost completely accurate
impression did i
plagiarize whitney houston by accident
you sounded just like her the fact that
she died in a bathtub
okay well is so took a turn tragic
and you know how much i love baths is
that my fate
to die in a bathtub how do you think i'm
gonna die oh um
uh it would definitely be at the hands
of someone else who
just yeah i mean i mean just literally
that's a statement
that was a statement that was i didn't
say me i said someone else who
killing me someone's gonna kill me
probably don't you think no
i'm just trying to make it interesting i
don't really know how you're gonna die i
think i'm gonna hit my head
on like a saddle in a barn and i won't
be able to get up
which is why you don't like saddles why
don't you use them you know
you know like i'm going to do i'm going
to be i'm going to like
this is a more big question i don't
really want to think about this for the
resolution how you're going to die
what i'm just saying it's an interesting
place to go
i think about death too much how
like i think you're going to die
making a ticket no i i think i'm going
to
die like trying to
clean what playlist will change this
mood
what playlist will fix what's happening
right now why isn't this why
why is this so okay good for you how are
you gonna die
you guys are thinking about dying alone
interesting thing okay um
it's a good year to think about dying
and then also blue light glasses my
other new year's resolution is i want to
wear the blue light glasses more
consistently
because we are on screens people go i'm
going to be on screens less that's not
going to happen
so you just want everything where are
the blue light glasses to be more
consistent
more consistent more concise concise
complete sentences be specific less
chaos
no i love i love me some chaos i love
good chaos healthy chaos
healthy okay oh words i also want to
stop exaggerating
[Music]
and generalizing so you know i like use
your words so instead of saying that's
not healthy
you say that's not helpful okay don't
over point
what is it so what you're this
relationship that
you texting him a million times that's
not healthy oh healthy i thought you
said the same thing twice i said that's
not helpful twice like wait what no
did i no that's not healthy and you want
to think that's not helpful helpful
oh okay healthy instead of helpful
that's not helpful georgia davis
and then though and then that will make
the the other person readjust what they
said so you can yeah and myself
why am i bullying myself that's that's
unhealthy
you're gonna talk to yourself different
too okay okay
starts with you really and um
yeah so i just wanted that's a hard one
too what now
the sleeping and the not generalizing is
a really difficult one
i i for me i think that'll be everyone
stop seeing everyone
everyone on twitter wants to cancel
david sedaris
everyone everyone
nobody liked my tweet nobody a better
thing to say would be there are
let me if only there was a machine that
could tell us exactly
the data oh look
422 people commented
on this situation
and of that like if i want to go down
that hole
of that 30 yard bots
of that 50
are follow alex jones
let me do what i mean give me the
specifics i want data
and i want it now everyone hates me
everyone hates you that's pretty
narcissistic
yeah send out a group text see what you
get back feelings aren't facts
feelings aren't facts what are your new
year's resolutions my resolutions are
well first of all i would like to give
the key to a city
and then i want to lose the key so much
that they have to give me a big keychain
is that relatable i i will lose it
that's my first one
i mean i want to lose it i want to call
the mayor so much they're like do you
want to keep giving me a big key chain
to go with my big key to the city
that seems fair the governor emailed me
who was it
garcetti yeah we'll just say his name
yeah sure whatever his job is he emailed
you
so i would like that i would like to be
write more
um or like be right more often which i
think is just about confidence
so i'm gonna work on that um
i would like to be um a victim
i would like to be a victim i would like
to stop being so strong and brave i
would
like to be um simple i would like people
to sympathize with me
i would like to post about it on all
social media platforms and i would like
to get the attention that i deserve
from my victimhood i think you get a lot
of attention i think
benton's become ben it's become by the
way like every celebrity's favorite
celebrity
people come in kesha hillary duff
they're all like where's benton
spanton likes freeman was like spent in
here can i get a picture with benton i'm
like jesus christ
and see i would like to be a victim i
think that's the next step in what i
want out of life
okay um so i should bully you more more
would be really hard
uh what else do i want to do i think oh
i would like to and then right after
that i want to bring peace to the
internet because you know give and take
i think i owe them something back
okay i'd like to fix the internet um
i would like to i would like to oh oh i
want to write a new york times
best-selling book and then i want to
change all my social media bios to new
york times best-selling author but no
other information not telling the title
of the book no that the new york times
is like all bought i would like for
other people to
to stop uh shooting down all my dreams
um
that's a resolution i mean i'm sorry
it's just but you're missing the point
after i get it
i want to change all my social media
bios to just tell you that's what i am
with no other information
okay i don't want to tell you what the
name of the book i wrote was new york t
y
yeah i don't want to tell you where you
can buy the book i just want you to know
that i achieved something and you didn't
that's pretty much what i want
um from that oh i'd like to write a
scripted show and then sell it and then
be told i'm too fat to play the lead
that seems fun different or never
experienced that
or do what happened to me which is uh
get um rich and successful and famous
that's not really my resolution i had a
different plan no um
i saw on the there used to be these
things called breakdowns um which were
all auditions i've seen them for actors
not nervous ones
um or emotional ones this was like uh
the breakdown services and would say all
the
like roles that were available to actors
and there was one that was a whitney
cummings type
we're looking for whitney cummings type
and i asked audition they said no thank
you
you're rejected by yourself they wanted
a whitney cummings type
they rejected you for you see that's a
resolution
i just i wanted to pick really
achievable resolutions this year and i
think i achieved that mm-hmm
and how long do you leave pie out
how long do you leave pie out can you be
more specific on what type of pie oh
thank you
you're helping me my new year's
resolution so i get an apple pie
i eat a piece in my day we put them on
the fucking
stove and they sit there for two weeks
and people walk by and they take bites
out of them
how long can a pie keep out in the open
like that
oil little foil on top uh i mean you i
i mean most people i think eat their
pies right away you know they eat them
they give them to
other people to eat slices but i would
say probably a couple days out like that
i know if you put
it in the in the refrigerator fruit pies
can last two
about two weeks i think oh wow because
of the sugar well because they're in the
refrigerator and they're not like warm
and heating
like you can't just anything sitting out
there like that i think is not good
why don't guys know that
women have different kinds of genes
as in like colors or for different
occasions or for different occasions no
because that is
everyone should have different jeans for
different occasions i have to i had to
pack for something
and i was like um lover please pack me
some jeans brings over my jeans and i'm
like
these aren't going out jeans these are
horse jeans these are the barn jeans
right how do you not know women have
barn jeans
horse uh maybe your lover only wears one
pair of jeans he only owns one pair
so that is now so that's like she puts
in the freezer
yeah a lot of red flags do you put your
jeans in the freezer no we don't know we
talked about this
i do not do that but i told you why um
so
there's going out jeans there's work
jeans
there's family fun day jeans there's
chores jeans
and chores you do your chores and jeans
yeah you need pockets
what kind of chore requires that i would
be in sweatpants
you're creating full looks for your
chores and then i put on my cape
because i i need to have my scissors my
cummerbund
right you're wearing a full utility belt
you need to have my monocle i think
you're just dressing for a job with a
handyman no i'm
just in the ymca she has the jean with a
little the hammer you know with the
hammer the little attachment
but you if you're doing chores you need
your scissors
your um swiss army knife
to your jewelry tape your duct tape
and your you know lighter what kind of
chores are these
what what you did not do chores as a kid
yeah i vacuumed i weeded the yard
never required all weed whacker i would
he did we did we did that's what they're
called
eaters right what we oh we need an eater
what do you call them
a weed whack we both have a speech
impediment
weed whacker yeah you call him a weed
whacker it was a weed whacker it was
like
are you jerking the weeds off what are
you talking about it's a weed eater you
cut them it's killing them
i didn't ask their consent this is crazy
a weed whacker
yes or you just weed them you pull
you de-weed oh no weeding is different
okay there's a spring spiraling we're
spiraling this is not the point
different genes for different occasions
i don't think people know that because i
think most people
um probably just have i mean no i agree
with you most people have different
genes for different occasions yes
i started to think that i didn't know
great there's there's going out genes
you got your black jeans your black
pants every woman has their black pants
their good pair of going out pants
yeah they're they're they're welcome to
welcome
nope we're clubbing pants clubbing pants
you're wearing pants at the club yeah
it's always the black pants from
you said i had a court case at nine but
i gotta climb the club at ten
yes that is not a thing yes uh give me
my um
charlie girl uh uh what is the brazil
bur what's the brazil bum bum bum bum
bum bum bum yeah
yeah brazilian crush is the name are we
even speaking english yeah
we are i know what you mean brazilian
crush are we over gifting
i'm really anxious about gifting i
cannot believe that you wear pants
to a club always that is the funniest
thing for her and then a little purse
yeah oh i'll get you the a clock club
every woman has their gauchos
club club i put on my gauchos and then
your black
uh uh pants that zip on the side
you watched too much sex in the city no
i we're just dressed as miranda i live
dead
no the black pants um uh bibi
minka kelly why are you with me on the
black pants i don't think that it's
the steve madden boots the aldo boot and
the black pants
and uh like the top you had your top
from express
limited express too
oh my god no that's not that's not the
the visual that i've seen my female
friends dress pardon b
agnes b like the top you had your top
your bright blue top are you sure you're
not just getting dressed to go work
primary color ad express
their music is always blaring remember
abercrombie and fish's
blaring club music no i remember coming
yes i do you walk in
you smell like it's like there's two
shirtless models on the walls oh do you
know the people why
no why you know that if you work on the
this is
this is um gossip i love retail gossip
you know that if you work on the floor
in america and venture hostile you're
called a model
no and if you work in the back on your
resume it says that
oh yeah they're hiring models and models
yeah and they have to there have to be a
certain quota a type this probably is
done now in 2020 surely to go around
there's no way that the shirtless
teenagers are still
like dry humping each other in the
abercrombie ads
oh yeah that's still happening for sure
and then the tank tops are sixty four
dollars
yeah and cargo shorts the booty cargo
shorts you know
same company that owns hollow shirt and
abercrombie oh it's all navy
so sponsors what does that tell you i
know why haven't i ever got an old navy
ad
also you're not coming why haven't i not
gotten an old name yet are you
commenting on my earrings
because i'm trying to ignore them
they're christmas tree earrings
i know i see them i wore them i can't
miss them i'm so jealous
i am not jealous of that we have i think
you have a very odd
uh opinion on what i like and dislike i
think
about resentments do we have any
resentments we need to release for the
new year
so that we don't have to carry around
resentments drinking poison
waiting for the other person to die yuck
yeah i mean i
all release resentment i do but i think
that if we did
if we did resolutions for the next year
we should do things that we're not proud
of we did this year
don't you i'm proud of i don't believe
in regrets i believe in things i
would have handled differently things i
would have handled differently things
i'm not proud of
i have a couple of those i was uh uh
with the one paris hilton nowhere heard
of her
uh doing uh i've heard of her a show for
her
on netflix and the director came out
and uh there's a
you know slow-motion amazing dp
um and they're doing slow-mo and i hear
music playing
and if it's slow motion you can't really
un-slow-mo it in post
production this is director virgo brain
and they're playing music and you can't
so if music is playing and you're
filming something that's gonna go on
television it's not usable footage
because you'd have to clear that song
and it's like a nicki minaj song and i
know that costs like
you know 100 grand as it should they're
not going to have a clear you got to pay
the songwriter you got to pay nicki you
got to play
pay universal you got to pay you know
request you gotta pay people turns out
whoever it turns out
so you can't clear it so i hear music
playing and paris hilton and and nikki
glazer's there and they're talking
and having telling these amazing stories
and just being super
funny uh and
i'm like there's music playing we can't
use this footage what do we
turn off the music and i'm in the show
and i start directing and i override
the director
and it's i will act shocked
no and i take over and i think i'm
helping
but i'm being insulting it's insulting
and it's rude
i was right on some level but
it was bad manners and it was
disrespectful to her
and i just wanted so badly to get for
her to get the footage to make the show
good
and i think a lot of people are you know
trepidatious to walk up to me and paris
hilton and
you know amanda cerny and nikki glazer
and saying like can you guys directing
us you know
that i was trying to help and i
embarrassed i think i in
yeah and then i apologize afterwards um
to her profusely um
and she's like whitney we've met five
times you're why i was like i've been
through this
she's like you're why i'm in a 12-step
program i was like thank you she's like
i've outreached
uh with you a lot i was like and then
she was like no no i drink now
you're not hearing me you're the reason
i go to a 12-step program
i don't think you're listening whitney
huh the mask
in fact i just lost my chips i just ate
my chip
yeah my over eating i'm hoping i choke
on it and overeaters and none of this
hey my chip side note your earrings
caught the light
they are gorgeous perfectly so you wish
you would have done that
i wish yeah like i i forgive myself i
that was a resentment that i held
against myself
and i have some resentments to the news
media
for the click baity shit and um blowing
things out of proportion
unnecessarily ruining people's lives and
and presenting things that aren't true
just to make money and humiliating
people
um and so for news i'm just gonna follow
uh jessica yellen and dr david agus
jessica yellen she knows it all
2020 she is the news truly like that's
where i go truly now i can't do fox i
can't do
uh cnn i can't do like cnn i kind of
i don't know you mean like real news i
don't like hollywood person to tell me
vox does a good job of deconstructing
the news sometimes
um but yeah i just want to be able to
learn i i don't want to get jupiter from
i say so you weren't talking about like
hollywood news you're doing a real news
but i was resentful towards
the fact that i'm like how i i wake up
every morning i'm like i
every news site says something different
this is fucking ridiculous
and why why are the boots that i tried
to order two days ago
on the side of on the fucking well
you'll you'll enjoy the information more
if you're happy and just made a purchase
no but i didn't want to i'll agree with
this if i have my new boots on
turns out i think it was an inside job i
was gonna fucking buy those
i didn't want to buy the boots and now
the boots are following me across every
website and i'm trying to
learn about coven
yeah buy these boots it's all fake yeah
so like
the distraught like i just want i want
like a new like is that the logic
so crazy what is your resentment um well
police
release resentment so they don't
crystallize i mean
i'm super resentful that i had to tell
everyone that i was a sweet boy and they
didn't know already
i mean i literally am a non-sexual
cherub like
i couldn't be any more cute or adorable
so i don't know why i had to say that i
don't think anyone
disagrees with you i don't know why i
needed to tell him i think you're
that's on you um no it feels like
it's my resentment or it's my thing i
wish i would have done differently okay
release
yeah it's gone now forget it everyone
knows everyone's forgiven
merch um you know i've also made some
pretty poor dinner choices
like i you know i get on uh doordash or
stop and
and i picked the wrong thing and then i
get it and that is just it's
disappointing and i should
be doing a better choice now this is my
real life whitney
this is how i live okay we're not fake i
use the sponsors
i'm not really thrilled with some of my
lukes i wore on the show
what okay there's some there's some
footage of me on here i would have i
would have done some things different
that's everyone
okay well forgive yourself i wasn't
doing serious ones either jokes
we could photoshop them out yes i need
the editors to go back in every
every episode and put me in new clothes
deep fake like one of those dolls
yeah that's what i want in fact just
make me scarlet johansen
can play anyone she can play me i think
that's pretty much
most of mine most of the things i wish i
would have done differently
that are hilarious moving forward is
there anything you want me to do
differently
i don't think we should talk about it
here
i need to work on myself first and
that's taking all my time
it's taking up so much of my time um
you think you have it together and then
you find out so
cassie david her book if you are a
youngin
if you haven't now is your resentment
you never have to tell me your
resentment dude i told you the news
oh i thought we were doing things
weren't proud of you already went to
resentment without me uh things i'm not
proud of
i told you about the director oh so you
just snuck in you're rising you're such
an old
married you snuck it in it's ridiculous
i was waiting for resentment no i'm a
segway bitch like i can
seg way through it's like just years of
stand up
comedy um so
this interview is very uh
i wish that i had this interview when i
was 25
22 so send it to your nieces uh your
nephews if they want to understand girls
that are anxious and confused and lost
and
um the female brain yeah send it to your
nephews let them know girls are people
yeah they're they're all different who
knew um it's kind of a
peek inside uh my 25 year old brain
her 25 year old brain she's 26
26. um uh
my now brain i'm bullying her to try to
get better make her better because this
is good for you
don't ride elephants like subscribe why
can't i
follow myself on spotify my uh
podcast well they're looking for a
whitney comings type to follow
you don't really fit that he's a genius
so people think i have good skin yes
people think you have great
people think you have nice skin thank
you for not exaggerating
even though i think it's great so it's
really difficult
this is a prescription skincare company
that connects you with a dermatologist
online who can prescribe you
online you don't have to drive there you
have to make 15 phone calls to get a
cream you have to go sit in a lobby with
a bunch of people
with a bunch of people that have wet
lizard skin because they've been in
there 26 times in the last month
or like my whole thing is when i had
acne
you have to put makeup on to go to the
dermatologist because you can't leave
the house with the acne and then you go
and they're like they see that you've
caked like shellac and cock and grout
into your pop
zits that you've like put toothpaste on
right and they're like well you
shouldn't be wearing so much makeup it's
causing your breakouts you're like no
bitch i had the breakouts first but i
did it to come here
because i couldn't let the people that
saw me on the way
see my zit yeah you're gorgeous remember
when i'm going to come in here and talk
to you you gorgeous dermatologist
so this is something where you just fill
out an online questionnaire about your
skin concerns and medical history and
then just snap a few makeup free selfies
privacy of your own home or
a park or a privacy of a park wherever
you are
and your dermatologist will get back to
you within 24 hours with a customized
treatment plan tailored just for you
they'll help you with skin care concerns
like breakouts
stress and the stress of driving to the
dermatologist is like i feel like this
is causing my problem
yeah stress hormones what you eat
there's so many they'll fix it all
they they help you with skin concerns
like breakouts dark spots
fine lines and wrinkles and even redness
and then the prescription creams come in
airless pumps that ensure those potent
ingredients stay effective
yes i love that we have we did it and i
love that we got a real dermatologist
that was
the best part is that they gave you a
real dermatologist online and
the the pump dermatologist i love that
we have to specifically you do nowadays
you don't know where it's the real
it's not like one of those ones that
just like yeah it's not like someone who
works like you know
in a beauty section they're like i know
a thing or two about a thing or two
get your first visit with a board
certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com for only five dollars
when you use our code whitney
this code is only available to our
listeners you could to get started just
go to apostrophe.com and click begin
visit and then use the code whitney at
sign up and you'll get your dermatology
visit for only five
dollars that's a p o s t r o p h
e dot com apostrophe dot com and use the
code whitney to get your dermatology
visit for only five dollars and we think
apostrophe for sponsoring the podcast
public goods this is cookies cakes hand
sprays
everything gorgeous beautiful
streamlined minimalist
i'll do it this episode is brought to
you by public goods it's a one-stop shop
for
affordable sustainable healthy household
products they care about the environment
and pets and all kinds of eco-friendly
things
hold on but the most important part is
it all looks like this
and i i'll send you the picture i have a
picture of my cabinet
everything brown box show the brown box
cookies everything looks like that
oh quaint how
adorable do you know how luxurious i
feel about my cabinet i said uh i'm
oprah
oh wait i don't want this to make
crinkling sounds for the people with the
asmr stuff anyway how cute is this
cookie box
it's just it's clean it i get stressed
out
by um tacky packaging
yeah why are you yelling at me with your
colors
of your font and i know we always tell
you about the packaging that's like the
thing that we're all drawn to because
um it's beautiful the why of the buy but
yeah that's the why of the buy but also
all these products are ethically sourced
and they're obsessively developed so
that each product is free of unhealthy
ingredients
they're actually good for you they're
good for you why are you promoting our
podcast
look at that look how it works
everywhere we worked out an exclusive
deal just for good for you listener
podcast listeners receive 15 off your
first public good order with no minimum
purchase
that's right they're so confident that
you absolutely love their product and
come back again and again
that they are giving you fifteen dollars
to spend on your first purchase
you have nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com whitney or use
codewhitney at checkout
that is p u b l i c g o o d s dot com
forward slash whitney to receive 15 off
your first order she's doing it right
now
okay are we friends
well when you were telling me to you
were like come on the podcast and i was
like okay and you were like don't worry
like it's totally comfortable because
like we know each other and if you
don't like anything like we can talk
about it i was like okay yeah that makes
me feel better because like we're
friends and that's cool and you were
like we're not friends
what are you talking about and i was
just like oh we're
yeah no we're not friends you were like
i don't know what you said but
everything you say to me on text
is so cryptic and i truly leave being
like so
confused whether you're like playing a
prank on me or not
we talked on the phone we talked on the
phone once
why um we
had both had a pilot at amazon
and so we were you know talking shit
about our
process i think that's what happened i
remember being on set
of an amazon pilot and all the
executives were talking about like
cassie david's pilot like that was the
thing
and i was like so jealous that
kazzy david had a pilot and it was gonna
be so brilliant and it's the next
fleabag
and i was on the set of my pilot
but we both got we both didn't get
picked up
like at the same time what was the
reason that they say that but also
why why were we making a show for a
grocery store
there was some relief in that like the
politics of
working for amazon are just like really
just like don't feel good and are very
conflicting so there is a relief in
being like
oh i'm really glad that i don't have to
try to justify this to myself for like
the next
few years because you want a show so
it's like oh my it's just like
a show yes of course yeah of course who
doesn't why
um what about it it's just like
such a i mean there's like a ton of
reasons but
for me i think it would be like the best
outlet for my comedy that i can just
keep
putting out into the world for you maybe
it's this podcast and you can
do your bits on your podcast every week
and you don't need to like
it's not it's not a lot of like
you know
right why why do you want to show you've
had many shows
obviously i'm aware
i'm just so fascinated by you
uh why is that
[Laughter]
imagine me being able to answer that
so you
what did you want and what did you get
um just in general
i i want to write
my stuff start it
like start doing it yeah i have
i think you know if people didn't like
my writing
or like you know going back like a few
years i would have stopped by now
so it's like yes i'm like still doing it
because
i feel like there are a few people i
don't know a few people but like
there's people i've reached with it so
otherwise i wouldn't have like
continued to do it and i'm not only
doing it because
i can't does that make sense
are you dating someone
[Music]
no do you want to
um yeah i mean
are you dating someone it's it's the
same
same yeah like would you if you were
dating someone would you want to talk
about it on this podcast
i mean i you don't give a shit i
you have blue hair we are the opposite
we are the opposite people
it's over like um
yeah i this is just this is you
in 10 years i don't think so i need to
find out i don't think why not
what is it um
i guess we should just start with the
hair like i think you look
fucking really awesome but it's not
something i
could do it would bring too much
attention to me
it's such a tricky word it is isn't it
that's that i feel like that's your lot
in life
attention because i because i want it
and
you you you hate fuck it yeah yeah
it's very primal what how do you like
what is your take on it i don't i
it's i i know that like benjen clowns me
on this
i think i'm like notorious
right i wouldn't call you notorious no
are we in a word fight i don't have that
many words
i have the smallest vocabulary ever
vernacular fight i have nothing
to fight with um no but i wouldn't call
you notorious
why do you think you're notorious i do
think that
women that are young and
noble can you noble can you manage my
vocabulary
for um nubile or nuble
can you use it in a sentence no women
who are young and nubile
yes that wants something
and get it are very triggering
for everyone yeah um it's a it's a it's
like
it's i i was just talking to a i
literally
no joke i know it seems like i don't
prepare for these podcasts because i'm a
hot ass mess but i called um
a neurologist named moran surf for me
before i
guess yeah oh okay
and we were talking about like memories
and and how our
brains process things under stress and
why we remember certain things and why
certain comments in the comment section
uh register more strongly than other
ones
etc and um
yeah i guess it's like i was asking him
i was like is anxiety a choice
you know which is like a hot take
and uh he's attractive so i was
getting distracted no joke
like and it just made me just be like we
are animals
and as i'm like watching you
i'm reading you i just i'm like
you are perfectly designed
for a thousand years ago
and why why because i can't survive
right with all this right now
because i can't yeah you're perfectly
designed to be in a tribe
in the dark with a lion
a huntin like hyper vigilant
neurotic anxious like you were the
queen of the tribe yeah i would have
survived you're the lead mayor
yeah thank you i think that's like
i think that's a compliment you're not
sure okay
apex warrior and so i like i'm just
i get very obsessed with people that are
perfectly
evolved and then everything else changed
and fuck them technology like just like
yeah whoa there's there's tomfoolery
there's an entire you know
the media is like the meanest girl from
your high school like they don't want
they don't care about what you look like
they don't care about reflecting you
accurately
they don't care if they embarrass you
it's childhood
yeah and it's just like you know
clickbait's like a very
real thing what like what when's the
last time you
just were like i nailed it
i've never felt like i nailed anything
um when i get away with something and
i'm like ugh
like people didn't make fun of that like
i nailed it
so you're a true stand-up in that you
want to control how you're going to be
embarrassed yeah i'm a stand-up with
stage fright so i can't do it
but so you should only be friends with
comedians uh yeah
that would be great if they'd like to be
friends with me i don't know you can
ask them if anyone's interested but yeah
i would like to
i feel the most comfortable when i'm
with people who are funny
comics yeah like because you're
sensitive but you're also tough
yeah you're not as sensitive as you
think you are
but people that don't get it are gonna
it's like earth-shattering when someone
doesn't get it yes or
they're gonna treat you with kid gloves
and it's like patronizing and
fantalizing
like what what's your ideal day
um like nothing bad happens
like nothing embarrassing happens
nothing happens my ideal day is like
worn into an embarrassing situation yeah
honestly like i was saying that
my dad said the other day like we sh you
know if this privilege thing is such a
problem we should have just like put you
up for adoption like i don't want this
i don't want this privileged kid like
this yeah because you're so like
tainted by yeah you're like beautiful
and you're
smart and funny and it's a nightmare no
i'm sorry
no it's about all of it stop people are
going to shit on me for that
i need to stop giving a shit but
honestly like i just like it's my first
go-around so like i'm
learning to not give a shit like what
what
when have you ever felt like present in
the moment like
this is what i'm supposed to be doing um
i do feel like this is what i'm supposed
to be doing which is why it's like
you know obviously writing yes yes and
of course it gives me like a lot of
anxiety but it's like
it's i'd rather be anxious and feel like
unfulfilled and like not
are you like hours and rand no
no no that's what and rand would say
thank you no i
am i don't i don't know what i am but
like
as i said i really just like i i i don't
i wouldn't put up with all the shit if i
i didn't feel like i was um
making some points that people can
connect to
did you record your audiobook i did how
did that go
oh my god it was like it's like truly
brutal first of all i have like horrible
vocal fry which
everyone listening eyes already
discovered your voices
in asmr dream
i i really sound like a man with
pneumonia
you're voicing like honestly like i'm a
man on his deathbed
so is like um you have a sinus infection
and i
sound like i have the sinus infection no
i gave it to you
earlier um i
you sound like whiskey whoa
you have like a whiskey caramel
like janice joplin it's everything
whiskey like puts you to sleep and like
i think i would put people to sleep if
it wasn't so it doesn't always some it
activates a lot of people too
it makes people make a lot of bad
choices i realize a vocal fry it's like
you
i used to do this on my web series a lot
which is like an embarrassing i had a
web series like
circle back to that sorry um but i was
embarrassed to say certain lines and i
realized like i would say them like
really low because i was like kind of
embarrassed to be saying them
mm-hmm and so all the comments were like
you've such bad vocal fry like can't
listen to vocal fry
and i was like oh i'm just like so
embarrassed to be talking that i like
go so low and then so that was my entire
audiobook i had a screen grab
also bent and said that you are like
ardaria
remember darya yeah i'll take that
benjen's really fucking killing it for
me
today dude benjamin i come in with like
nothing and benton's like
benton tells me what to think um he's my
neurolink um yeah like
like did you ever see my so-called life
you're like angela well she she wasn't
the main character she's like the first
angela was yeah
there it is oh really yeah no you're not
i remember being like kind of quiet and
yeah she was like anxious and
uh wanted to date jared leto do you want
kids
uh it goes against my morals but yeah i
do because i'm selfish
uh that like no person actually
like chooses to be alive and it's like
very selfish and you do it for your own
happiness and fulfillment yeah it's like
masturbatory
yeah and um are you into terror man do
you want kids
my deal with kit wow manage her
jesus uh micro manager please
um no i froze my eggs when i was 33
and i uh i
do want how old are you now how
this bitch the click
bait bitch has the gall i don't want to
talk about myself
i know you're sick of yourself i know
it's a tricky one it's like i got
i feel like you're a little bit in the
moment where i
when i had like that moment when i had
like three shows on the air and i had
all this didn't i felt this exposure and
i was like overexposed and i was like
everybody's sick of me but i know i have
to do press
you know and i have to keep talking
about myself and i know you kind of hate
me and
it's just like this weird
self-flagellating like cycle what was
the headline that like you
hated the most that you got that i just
didn't reflect you at all
vanessa gregoria i'm a fan
she nope i'm just blasting
people that don't deserve that followed
me around for like five days
and i was doing a talk show and to come
and uh
whatever the fuck ever and uh
and she was like saw me like i mean i
like had pneumonia i had
migraines like i was like trying to make
shows i was like fighting with network
executives like
um making two part girls and she
uh and then the headlines said whitney
cummings
is everywhere whitney cummings works
harder than anyone why can't she get any
respect
it's just like you said something really
s like interesting to me which was that
like faint like um
respect is the new fame like no one
you don't want to be famous anymore you
just want to have respect and that's
like
the coolest thing ever and for me that's
like always been like what
anyone would like actually choose to
strive for i agree
but um i agree with myself
and my answer would have been different
10 years ago
like i 10 years ago i want to be famous
now i want to be respected you know what
i mean
yeah um but the more you try to be
respected the less people respect you
which is why i developed this shit with
horses
and you've not done any ancestral
examination which is very odd to me my
dad's done it so i know like his lineage
but my mom hasn't done it
my family is like is really weirdly
secretive like no one knows anything
about their parents
like no one knows like what their
grandparents names are that's
interesting
maybe that's part of why you want to
like expose so much
you mean like about my life mm-hmm yeah
i think it is about that from
youtube maybe why i'm never having
before
uh like around the world no no no
the main thing for me is that i uh i
like to have like routine in my life
yeah yeah and um i have a
i have a fear of throwing up that like
really runs my life throwing up yeah
so when i travel it like um
there's less certainty that i'm not
gonna throw up
honestly i'm so sorry that's so wild
yeah so you're worried you'll throw up
in a public place
no it's not about public place it's just
the act of doing it i'm scared i'll get
sick
i'm scared i'll like you know like eat
from somewhere like
i don't i haven't a million times before
i don't
um will happen it's just like my biggest
fear
so you just avoid it at all costs but
it's like it's weird because
i remember my therapist like she what
she does is
is she walks you through your worst fear
mm-hmm and then you like have to lift
i've heard that and i've heard people
with uh metaphobia who
literally expose themselves to throwing
up so they can
get over the fear and that's just like
ins like that's just like so much i
would never
do that but why
you're the safest anyone could be
just in life yeah like
globally like you're probably the safest
yeah probably
does that like math at all do you ever
go like oh mathematically i'm this
statistically the safest person
no because you can't actually like ever
protect yourself
from the things that can happen to you
like yeah
seriously yeah and you find new things
out every day that like can happen
yeah like bugs and eyelashes type thing
yeah or kovid
but do you feel like um i know that i am
addicted to
adrenaline you are what do you do for
that do you go skydiving
no no no no i in utero
like what was when your mom was pregnant
what was the situation
well there was the 94 earthquake when
you
while you were pregnant when my mom was
pregnant so
i think that's a that could potentially
be a factor
you were in utero hmm yeah
ow but i think it'd be crazy to blame it
all on that there's like a lot of
different
factors my mom is like insane
an insanely anxious person but we're
designed to be anxious
yeah anxiety is good sorry yeah
also i'm not by any means like trying to
be like the poster child for
anxiety like i it's like i don't want
i think there's a point where like
you'll
want to stop talking about it i i
already want to stop yeah
yeah it's like it's because i've done
this like i've done this thing where
you're
i wrote a book that is way less good
than yours
and not true but thank you um
i like was like wrote about eating
disorders and all this
in sexual assault and then everyone's
interviewing about and i'm like why are
you asking me about this
yeah no it's um it's
i'm talking about it because it's like
so part of like who i am that i
like don't it's just like the first
thing that comes to mind like doing this
like yeah i'm like anxious
and like you know what like anything
that you do in life
you're anxious about it yeah so i i talk
in the book because it's something like
everyone
can relate to and but you should be
you're you're thin you're small you're
young you're beautiful
like statistically you are prey
like it's a really big compliment to be
called i guess like who knew
i'm just saying this is we should have
georgia here like
this is the shit that's like so primal
that i get in trouble for which is like
why wouldn't you be scared
we're in a pandemic you're beautiful
you're young
you're prey doesn't it kind of track
wouldn't it be weird if you weren't
scared
i think it's weird if i think it's weird
that anyone's not scared
yeah like people aren't scared you're
like that person's crazy look at that
person like just without a mask
you know what i mean no you're crazy if
you're not
crazy what is your like morning routine
i wake up
i go to the news i wake up
i like manically check my phone to make
sure like nothing horrible
you have it on uh silent when you sleep
yeah i have it on thailand all the time
because i check it so much that i don't
need it to vibrate
yeah like i'll see it when someone texts
me i'm staring at it all day you know
you've never watched tv
like on a tv yeah what do you mean
obviously i watch tv but do you watch it
on a tv screen
i think yeah as opposed to a computer oh
can we kill that by the way
yeah like do we like do you watch a tv
a box yeah not a box but i like a
flat screen i'll watch tv yeah
okay and what did you watch wearing up i
was obsessed with gossip girl like
obsessed
great there's something about watching
like nothing really bad can happen to
these characters they're all
like wealthy that was your 90210 yeah
yeah i also watched the
remake of 902 and now and not as good as
gossip girl but got me through
tuesdays i thought it was on yeah uh
yeah those were my like go-to's do you
blame romantic comedies for
your what you expect in relationships
no um
no because i i think if you have like a
low threshold for
bullshit and you're watching romantic
comedy you're just like this is
so stupid and like obviously you know
it's stupid yeah
i mean even kids should like watch that
and be like this is stupid
you would hope because it's so stupid no
how bad has this press tour been um
almost it's been like so bad like i
don't even know if you know
like i i've been googling you yeah it's
bad
it's really bad it's not bad it's it's
just not
natural it's not um we're not designed
for it
we're not wired for it no we're not i
also don't know if you saw what happened
like with my like excerpt
oh sex when you have full your stomach's
full yeah
yeah that that seemed to make the rounds
yeah
and i was so shocked by it because for
me it was like
this is so obvious that's not even like
worth writing about like it's something
like everyone knows about like it's
probably been a joke a million times
yeah and that was not the reaction it
was like
first of all it was satire it was like
absurdist but it's like based on like
yes you to me you're very gary steingart
to me
cool um
loving these references i have so many i
if you mix all these people together i
want nothing more than to be friends
with cazzy but i have to
like down like upload my hippocampus
into her brain
she knows my references so we can be
friends yeah we have to get there
i need to you need to give me a list of
things i need to like
educate myself on um but yeah so i
first of all i was it's kind of like
you know when you re you release an
excerpt it's kind of like
releasing the wrong single for an album
if it's not like reflective of the book
that's funny
yeah i don't think it it was but it's
just like a funny
stupid piece and but it really was just
a piece about
being in a relationship and like being
in a comfortable relationship but also
like like the internet like
it's also on us to stop taking it so
seriously i think
you know this is a hot take like 22
percent of people are on twitter of that
two percent generate 80
of the comments it's like we also have
to stop
amplifying it we also have to stop
taking it so seriously
like it's sort of because then i'm like
how many how
people send me an article about me and
they're like you're canceled look you're
like trending on
whatever and i'm like okay but 800
views like it's so
silly it feels like a rumor it's like a
rumor in high school
that we now like because it's on a
screen that like was really like hard to
make and was made in a fancy place right
and has like shiny buttons like we think
it's like
everyone's seeing the same stream we're
seeing yeah but it's
really shock like the fact that there
was like a reddit page like discussing
my anatomy and that i like don't know
how sex works or food works and
that i have an eating disorder that i'm
like uh
you know it was just like so beyond like
like how many people were on that reddit
chain you know what i mean
no i don't like it once there's like
articles written about like what people
are tweeting
yeah but i was like always like the
second that there was like
two articles about me and the headlines
were like
like toxic like hollywood girl or like
privileged girl like everyone no matter
what excerpt i accepted it would have
been like
i think people were ready to like tear
me apart which is like i i would have
done this is that what you feel like has
happened to you
like what it's so funny like i don't
because i
what i do when with people like someone
like you
my research was like i texted a bunch of
people that are like your age
and i was like what do you think about
this person
and they're like megan fox uh
of young millennials uh
super funny witty um
incredible writer what's your favorite
animal
uh maybe a deer
you love deer yeah why
they're scared of everything i mean that
is such an amazing she's a d
you're a deer truly
that's wild but it's like but it is this
thing where it's like i watched and i've
talked about it before like with
roseanne like i watch roseanne need to
be hated
you know like i i've i've seen people
need negative attention i don't think
that's what you
are you know that i like
i certainly don't need it but i don't
think you want it do you know what i'm
saying
no but do you think people there's
people who want it
yes i think there's people that have
legitimate shame addictions and i think
adrenaline turns into dopamine
and i think a lot of people's comfort
zone is being the victim
and like i know how to do this it's like
the devil i know
you know there's all these studies of
these um
kids that um they would rather be
abused than ignored because at least
you're getting some kind of attention at
least you like understand what's
happening
you know and why kids like bang their
heads
against walls because they need to know
that it's solid
you know like i don't do well with gray
area i'm very black and white
yeah you know um
but it's interesting to me that like
because i feel like you
when i when you were a topped when i was
like a teenager
there was like tabloids like we had
tabloids we had the inquirer we had star
like we had
like last week it was like a magazine
that you were like people like
instagram so addictive dude we always
had this shit we
always like i would go into doctor's
office and be like
but don't you think like on some level
the comments have gone from like
uh like not for me like you suck to like
dissecting your entire character and
upbringing in like everything about you
or do
you think that's how it's always been
comments but like how can you take a
comment seriously if you don't know who
who's making it i mean personally i
would just like
never be friends with someone who could
like talk shit about something on
twitter
but you know that somebody who is angry
is just
sad in pain anger is always just pain or
sadness
yeah but i guess it's like i i relate to
it because like i'm like
sad and angry and like hate everyone
yeah yeah yeah yeah so i'm like
oh like would i hate me like you know
you guys have the most in common
yeah you hate me great yeah we have
something in common i hate me too
let's do this like you know what i mean
it's like it's just throwing rocks like
it's just
it's like it's the new egging houses
it's not personal
you know like i think that like we just
have to make this dramatic shift of like
how we're
perceiving um like
tribal childish behaviors we used to
toilet paper houses we used to throw
eggs at houses
do you know what i mean we used to it is
but it's really easy to shame people
remember we of like
shank people we are wired to humiliate
other people
yeah and it's all testing each other to
see who
in the tribe uh is the alpha
and who is safe and who is going to
protect who
it's like it's like we always did that
shit but now there's cameras
and now there's we can do buying
computers and it just looks different
yeah i mean no but it's true so the
media is like
it's truly they they
do not care about anyone they do not
consider
why would they it's a business yeah like
why would they
no i'm not expecting them to but you do
realize like oh wow like
you like do not see people as people
like at
all but that but we don't see them as
people
the media yeah you know what i mean like
they're just robots that are supposed to
be flattering us all the time
you know this is like i think we're just
in this like this will get me handsome
like this chinese finger trap of like
i want it on my terms all the time you
know like i'm such a hypocrite where i'm
like
i want you to cover me and make me
famous but i want on my terms and i want
to be flattering but no one's getting
dopamine from that no one's getting
adrenaline and dopamine from that
people are only clicking if cazzy david
lashed out i was just talking to this
neuroscientist
that um and i should just have him
we'll figure out a way to just put it in
the podcast that like
when a news article says
someone lashed out cazzy david slams
so and so it's like a 15
more release of cortisol in your brain
and you're more likely to click on it
opposed to cassie david addresses the
rumor
slams you know what i mean and i'm
obsessed with that because
in stand-up we say you bombed you killed
you murdered you i'm obsessed with like
the words we use like
i did a joke a couple specials ago about
like how
um guys say like i murdered that shit
like
like i killed that like i'm i'm kind of
obsessed with how violent men describe
sex yeah um so i'm
you know it's like we're just we're
animals you know it's a feeding frenzy
and you're kind of just like
you're delicious you're like the your
scarlet letter
yeah i but it felt like this whole i'm
like sorry bring this up again but like
i i felt like i did something you've
only apologized once
which is shocking i've been trying to to
do it less i was
actually like given a note like you need
to stop apologizing yeah it's
it's just like it's i know and everyone
hates it um
but i felt like i had done something
like wrong i was like
i feel like i me toot someone like
that's how people are like
like when was this when this whole week
like oh this week yeah yeah yeah we're
just like
chilling on me you're like whatever it
was what where
like twit i don't know what do you mean
everyone's posting about you
no it's just like people you're just
going to only focus on the negative
yeah yeah yeah i guess i don't know
when you're on the today show yeah
what what what so it's your focus
well it's like my friends being like um
this is like not good but like you need
new friends
who are your friends yeah i don't know
but
but i i feel like i was like someone
with a bot
with five followers saying
she's privileged that's an adrenaline
addict
that's like a a chaos dramatic yeah
but it's a little only but it's the only
it is the only question i'm asked is
like what's it like growing up in like a
hollywood family blah blah and then i i
answer and i'm not like trying to
who cares exempt myself from it yeah i'm
just like that's
part of who i am and i i'm like just
trying to own it and
yeah it's just like would you rather me
pretend like it's not a factor
do the thing do the thing ready closer
to the mic
the thing yeah that's a lollipop
lollipop you we
us the royal we love the ollie pops i
just said fuck under my breath is that
okay
is that okay she said i was like fuck
that's good you know what it is i just
to me nostalgia is my drug
i think control and sometimes drugs but
ollie like orange squeeze look at the
packaging of this doesn't it feel like
it feels vintage it goes down to the
pharmacy to get a phosphate in the 50s
yes
you're going to get that in a candy bar
and then you're going to solve a crime
for a young lady who doesn't know what
to do
oh henry you said oh oh you oh girl you
bring your car break down take this
olive oil i'm going to fix your tires in
a car with no seatbelts she's like
please sir please i never had olive oil
before so please and you're like what
he's like he's been dead for 40 years
i love the cherry vanilla one of the
strawberry vanilla ones so it's like
i'm so bummed that we grew up with toxic
sodas
like we didn't get we like drunk out of
a hose and drink just like random
chemicals
this is it has prebiotics which i didn't
even know that was
prebiotic i know i thought it was
probiotics
i was that's about it before my body i
have so many biotics
it's botanicals plant fiber sparkling
tonic and the flavors are just you know
what i'm gonna do this soda supports
healthy digestion
digestive and immune health isn't that
great i would really appreciate
everyone get your immune system in order
can everyone just
pull it together with your immune system
not only that but did you know ninety
percent of americans consume more than
the u.s
uh da's daily uh recommended added sugar
intake
do you wanna do that again the no these
sodas have less sugars that's the point
the point is there's not a lot of sugar
in these and they're better for you you
got it you understand what i'm saying no
sure
so the fact that we ate that much soda
we should sue our parents
non-gmo vegan paleo keto friendly for
all you punks out there
less than eight net carbs it's also it's
just like i don't know i just
think we got to take the wins and they
have a lot of great flavors too
can i finish we've worked out an
exclusive deal for the good for you
podcast listeners receive 20 off plus
free shipping on their best selling
variety pack this is a great way to try
all their delicious favors go to drink
olliepop.com
whitney to use code whitney and check
out to claim this deal that's
d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p dot com slash
whitney this discount is only valid for
their variety pack which is the pack you
want trust me lollipop can also be found
in over 3000 stores across the country
including whole foods sprouts krogers
wegmans and erawan
iq treat mats can help keep your dogs
calm during stressful situations
studies show that repetitive licking can
actually
increase endorphins in the brain helping
to soothe
pets love it
benton but if people do that it is very
strange
sorry if you're a people licking
yourself
we don't we don't recommend actually
it's good
oh wait can you eat it is it for people
too i just did
it no don't we're not this isn't double
there
double dare hyper pet is offering good
for you listeners 50 percent off their
first iq treatment order go to
iqtreatment.com
whitney to browse our selection of slow
feeder mats and use the promo code
15 good for you for 15 off at checkout
until the end of the year
while you're there check out their other
interactive dog toys to help keep your
pet active and enrich this winter
co-sign this even if they weren't a
sponsor
stop thinking your dogs like
have a schedule yeah help your pets
through their feelings of isolation
anxiety and boredom
give them a nice little treat what's the
question you get asked the most
mine is is it hard being a woman in
comedy yeah
is it the answer is yes
it's uh what what's it like growing up
in a you know
with like in a hollywood family or like
as a
like privileged
i don't know think of larry david as
being hollywood i think of him as being
like comments
yeah yeah but it doesn't matter anymore
because that's like
it's a
it's like being a woman in comedy it's
like i'm so i'm a child of a celebrity
i'm so much more interested in you being
26. that's to me so much more into well
i wish i could like
like again that's like not something i'm
trying to run on like it's just the
question i'm asking and turning to the
headline
like i would like to be like talking
about like what it's like to be a young
person
in today's world and and that's why i
like wrote this
and that's why people relate to it it's
not because i'm
for real no bullshit if a guy wants to
date you
what do they do like what's your perfect
like if they're not gonna like your if
you were gonna script it out
in your next show which will happen if
you want if you want it
um like how does it go
um he's how old i would like a 31 32
that seems like cool okay like not
trying to
have another girlfriend after you you
know got it
potentially got it gotta go um
[Music]
makes fun of everything is important to
me
gets old after a while does it though
it has to you have to kill do don't be
on all the time but don't take yourself
so seriously
it's just like let's just hate the same
things as me yeah yeah
like you have to make fun of everything
maybe about that i always thought there
was a dating app like that that was like
because they i always looked i always
got on those apps like raya and um
pinch hinge and bumble and stuff and
it's always like things i like i'm like
dude why don't we do dislikes yeah
if there was a date i'm not on any
dating apps but if there was a dating
app for like people who hate everything
like
yeah when i'm with like if i'm with a
guy
that's uh that's literally what every
executive asks me when
i'm writing a script like why because
my characters are like always people who
like hate everything and they're like no
one's going to like this person if
they hate everything they have to find
somebody david and he has the house in
brentwood
from not liking things do you want
a wedding in the whole thing no
you want to be like me just no
no no no i'd like something else
like my own thing that's you know you're
doing your thing and
maybe i'll you know have my thing
version of like what
like because i think it's like people
like you you just have to
cater to your genius
like there's no blueprint for you
sorry i'm sorry i'm just like helping me
why why what ask me
no i uh i know i mean i i don't know
anything
yeah no me either i really don't but
like what what's what's
tomorrow what would be the perfect day
for you tomorrow a show gets picked up
on
am on netflix stand-up special
can't do stand-up i really want to
though
i actually was perfect time to start
yeah i inquired to you about it
but actually before quarantine i was
like i'm going to
film a stand up my friend's just going
to film my stand-up special yeah there's
not going to be an audience
it's going to be a joke like yeah
because i can't be in front of an
audience i'm too scared
yeah and then covet hit and then
everyone started doing that and i was
like never mind i can't ever do that
what um so this is what happened with me
in your book i started reading your book
and what i try to do sometimes is just
like open to a page and see what happens
like i like that's a fun game it's a
dumb game and i open
to you uh
writing fucking tweets i would tweet if
i weren't morally opposed to twitter
in order to cook an octopus they have to
beat them to death because if you try
and kill one instantly the octopus's
muscles tense up
and the texture is too hard to eat sorry
i just didn't want to be the only one
who knew that
and i literally like threw the book down
it was so upset it's impactful
i'm trying to get people to stop eating
octopus
i mean i talked about it with robert
green for two hours i mean it's like
but i i you have what i have um
no offense um insult to you compliment
me
that of like i have a little bit of a
fetish
for hurting myself it's like a mo it's a
cutting but like emotional
like this entire book was hurting myself
yeah
me being on this podcast is self-led
i mean but how are you is this like
who knows what i said i yeah you know i
was like let me finish the job you guys
and uh
cancel myself officially but why but
you're not
like i don't think you can be canceled
if you're
self-aware and i think that i think that
the thing with canceling
is that it's only people that pretend to
be one thing and we're seeing really
another
if you have a book like what i mean i
did the roasts yeah but that's
i feel like that's that's something i
did think you know if you're
like you know true to who you are and
you're not like
faking anything no secrets but your
generation doesn't have secrets like my
generation we have secrets we have like
photos floating around of us
in blackface like at like halloween
parties that's like a
physical photo that like i don't know
what attic
there's a photo of me like in a geisha
like makeup or some shit like
no but the things that we have now will
be like
that in you know 20 years but i feel
like you guys like
have an idea like you guys are so aware
that everything is being recorded that
you walk in eggshells everyone i think
is totally scared of being publicly
humiliated
even the people who aren't known because
you can be yeah
even can be an anonymous 14 year old
girl and if you do something stupid
everyone can know about it and it's like
really it's
surveillance yeah it's china i mean it's
like what china did on purpose we
now do by accident but you realize you
can make fun of fucking anything
and it'll be embarrassing so it's not
even about like oh you're just cautious
of it and you just don't do anything
wrong so you would
anything could be wrong when you were a
kid and people did you notice people
recognizing your dad
yeah but i i grew up in la and and so it
was like less
you know in new york it was like oh
everyone i guess jewish and like yeah
there's so much ancestral trauma yeah
with you
you don't want to know about it i know i
would like to know about it i think
because we carry so much like guilt and
shame it like
imprints on our dna like so much of it
isn't your fault
like you get it honestly like you this
is how you should
be if you are like believe science
yeah i just really feel like i'm turning
into the like
you know but you realize that it's like
that's like the thing where i'm like
you every time you talk you just realize
like what about it could be made fun of
they like make fun of things that you
wouldn't they make fun of jean jackets
so what if they do then what it's just
like you're aware of it but i have this
thing that's like if someone
is hates you they love you like they're
obsessed with you if someone's going if
someone's following you
and commenting on your shit and going
like your book sucks it's like well you
read it thank you you bought it thank
you
thank you yeah your book sucks someone
read my book
and thought it sucked this is great news
did the transaction clear like i'm not
allowed to make you
i'm not allowed to have the expectation
that you need to like it
i just put it out yeah you don't have to
like it
i don't even like it that much yeah how
much do you like this book
i liked it for a little bit it's pretty
good i mean you're a pretty good writer
but
you probably have notes on it too like
so it's like
why like i just well also every time
anyone does something like it's for only
like us
a certain type of person like it's only
for like a couple
you know versions of a person but how
much of it is
like don't take this the wrong way
i can cut it out like how much of that
is like
i just try to go every day when i wake
up and i have like a story about myself
i'm like how much of this is true and
how much of this is me just like the
story i've written about myself like i'm
a writer like i can rewrite things
this is why i love training dogs and
horses because you see how quickly they
can
you can change can you train me yes
how quickly you get a dog that trusts
nobody and is scared of people
and then two days later they're in your
lap and you're like wait a second we
this is the same
composition the same matter these are
same neural pathways it takes 28 days to
make a new neural pathway so it's like
like am i am i attached to this
role am i attached to this story
you know what i mean i'm like i don't
trust anyone i'm like dude do i not am i
that person
i hate myself do i hate myself like i
say that and it gets a laugh
like i don't think i do but it's like
you know like i just have to like
sometimes step back and like reevaluate
and make sure it's not true
well if you have like a you know kind of
faulty self-image
and then like your identity is like
being formed
without your consent yeah yeah yeah yeah
um it's hard to differentiate yourself
from like what
like your new identity is
and like what you know to be true
because when i think of you
i go she's so resilient she's so strong
and you're like i'm so fragile by a
thread so it's like
it's just such an interesting like i'm
like but she just like went through all
this public madness
and like wrote a book which is a fucking
nightmare
and made this show that did i've done
all those things
you know and i'm like oh i know how i
know what you went through because i
went through it
i haven't gone through the stuff with
the famous dad but like
it's really hard having a dad that loves
you sounds very traumatic
um honestly uh i'm not even i'm not even
joking no no no because like it
i think that having parents that are
like really available and solvent
really does not equip you for the real
world
yeah well also you just like spend all
your time being like what the fuck am i
gonna do like when you're gone
like yeah i like can't even fathom like
how i'll be able to
yeah survive without this person yeah
and like worrying is
part of is our deal mm-hmm you know and
like we get it
i just i guess my thing is like i mean
and i'm in you know this i'm in 12-step
programs and stuff it's like
how do we like like transmute
these pathologized character defects and
like qualities into something
positive like will you put it into work
that's what i'm saying
yeah why isn't it all good why can't
this be good i'm super anxious i fucking
wrote a book
by 26. i because i guess it's because of
what and it's really it's stupid
but yeah that's how that's how it should
be framed like yeah like i just think we
need to like i think your whole
generation like
looks to you and like relates to you and
like
i just i'm always about reframing the
way we talk about women's behavior
from she's sensitive she's crazy she's
irrational she's
psycho she's a stalker she's emotional
to like
she's productive and she's perceptive
and she's observant and she's prolific
and she's thoughtful
and she's fucking smart you know what i
mean like i just think
all of the things that's that i just
might wish for you would be that you see
them as superpowers
instead of as flaws yeah
yeah i mean like you're a hyper empath
like super hero
but society's told you these are all bad
things
i think um if you're like an obsessive
person and like
someone says something to you and you
just like obsess over it yeah and so i'm
just like getting through the
obsessions of like what yeah yeah
but it's like also i'm really sorry like
did not come on this podcast and like
we did not like i was not funny no i've
never finished instead you like
literally you gave me a full therapy
session no i didn't i'm not i'm not
being helpful at all it wasn't this was
therapeutic i've lectured
it's not even we haven't started we're
not even
we're two hours in where i don't even
know but like i just um
um i just that that's like when i like i
look at you
like i mean i felt compelled to like
call you when your pilot didn't get
picked up because i was like i've
fucking
been there dude and like i just want her
to know
so badly that that was the best thing
that could have happened to her
yeah like i don't know how to tell her
and like i guess you just the only way
out is through i guess you just have to
i found out my pilot didn't get picked
up on 9 11 which was like the most
like it's like it was just like wild um
but what was the reason my
book is about the day of the vegas shoot
we had to cancel all the press and i
didn't get to do press for it i did a
week later and after the vegas shooting
i'm on talk shows being like
i had an eating disorder
i think you have more choice in
the way you're perceived than you think
yeah does that make sense
yeah no i'm i'm a hundred percent still
trying to manage it
because i feel like you're living in a
little bit of shame i'm always living in
shame yeah but it's very narcissistic
it's like i can't be
how's it working it's so i i'm just
like honestly like i'm just i have a lot
of growing up to do
and like that's like a lot of what this
book is yeah yeah
and i was reading it i was just like
this is exactly what you should be
thinking yes this is exactly what you
should be saying this exactly
oh my like i was like i wish this book
existed when i was 20.
i think so that's really nice like that
would have been my i would have been
like holy fuck there's someone else that
fucking thinks like this
i mean there's someone else that's this
confused or someone else is this anxious
and this fucking restless and irritable
and discontent like that's
your daria thank you yeah no it's like
you're stop talking to people that are
older
that's what you know what i figured it
out stop talking to anyone over 30
myself included no but i don't think
it's
i think it's i don't know if it's that
because
my i don't know my because the
like your young friends are like really
tuned in with what's going on no mine
but if they tell you like
yeah like everyone thinks you're like
transphobic
and like fat phobic then you're like
oh okay and if you're friends everyone
imagine
imagine that's like a climate denier
everyone thinks you're transphobic no
but then you start
you start having to defend yourself to
your friends generalizing
and being that bad at math and saying
everyone thinks you're something
yeah honestly my therapist is like you
literally are not allowed to use the
word everyone or like
everything everyone you can't use those
words yeah i texted you this like i'm a
piece of shit in the center of the
universe
it's that it's like everyone and my
therapist said once she was like i have
good
because i was like obsessing over what
someone was thinking about me and i was
like this person's mad at me
and she was like um i have good news and
bad news nobody's thinking about you
they're obsessing about themselves it's
no it's like the most embarrassing thing
how much
you can care about yes yourself yes i
have to go to this party i have to go to
this party what if i don't go to this
party
they'll be fine the party will go on
without you
yeah it'll probably be better they're
frankly not going to cancel it
you showing up out of obligation is
going to fuck up the party frankly
and then can you imagine if someone came
to your party because they thought they
had to because they thought you'd be mad
at them
yeah please don't come mm-hmm you know
like i feel like
are you do you take it but you know
there's some people who like do care and
they're like
i take xanax that's all
i started taking prozac because i
i had gary goldman on and he was talking
about depression and he's like you know
obviously like the ninja and all that
stuff and he
was telling me like you know because i
like can get i can totally get out of it
i have too much energy i'm like manic
you know i'm like talk so fast i can't
even like get words out something like i
stutter because i talk so my brain goes
faster than my
which is why by the way i didn't want to
start a podcast for the longest time
because nobody knew that i had a like
stutter
um and uh you know i'm a stutter i don't
but sometimes i'll
like slur because i'm just yeah but
that's just like being a person i know
but
you're used to vocal fry my job we don't
i
i've given off the uh impression and
scripted television and stand up that i
speak very clearly and loudly but if you
hear me in conversation my brain just
goes a little too fast
for my um horse mouth and uh
i don't even know why i'm on this
tangent yeah no but give it give it tell
me because it was important
i don't remember oh no oh so so i
basically gary goldman i was like
i'm not i can get out of bed i have too
much energy i'm a total workaholic i'm a
spaz i'm going to say that word um
if this version worked i would do it if
worrying worked i'd worry
it's just like i tried it for so long
and it just didn't work
there's i think you're just going to
come to a point and everyone your age i
think two where you'll just go like well
that just didn't work
so i'm just gonna try the other thing
and if worrying
like the um my dog recently got his
like leg cut off in like a freak
accident
yeah that's the worst thing i've ever
heard it was like it was like split open
oh my god
and all i do is worry about keeping my
dog safe he's like bubble wrapping them
and like keep and then i'm
defeating them and i make their chicken
and i'm the pills and i grind the pills
up
and i'm like and i'm going to get
putting olive oil on their thing and
salmon oil
and then he's out of my sight for two
minutes and
like just a freak thing on a step it was
just like
the one thing i didn't plan for and it
was just like oh even the worrying
didn't
prevent something from happening that
didn't even work so i kind of am now
like
i'm just experimenting with the free
fall
just to see if it's as
good or better you know yeah like you
might just kind of be like huh
i'm good like that like
just didn't work that well i'm like try
this new thing because like i the thing
i worry about is that
guys will want to rescue you and you'll
get these like codependent
like guys i feel like it's the opposite
like i'm always the one like
oh god oh god
ew do you conflate love and pity
no but i do i have like a i am like
constantly trying to like
help them do what like survive in the
world
like what how so like if i find someone
that's like
worse at living just like day to day
than me
i can like stop
like nothing you're i don't see you
being bad at anything
what are you bad at
[Laughter]
you wrote a fucking brilliant book
you're
what like what like on a day-to-day like
finances
yeah i can't do that that's hard not as
hard at math really bought them out yeah
no that's fair
me too okay okay but that's okay yeah
what are all these drinks for like is
this for me
it's a test it's you know a therapist
when you walk in their office there's
all these toys on the table
and you pick one up and they like
scribble something down and you're like
they're all cold too like someone
brought all of the drinks up because i
just wanted you to have like every
option
thank you um how do you feel this is
going and is there anything else
do you have any questions for me yeah i
have a ton of questions for you
um and then maybe when we talk about you
you guys can just make that the whole
thing i know it's such a bummer like
it's it's
i think i think ultimately this is my
dream for you is that you have like a
donald glover career
where you can kind of like go away and
make your show for a year and then it
comes out
and people just see your work and then
you can like go away
because i think you're kind of going
like oh
this is not what i signed up for that's
like been advice i've been given it's
like
hey if you don't like this like you
won't do it and it's like
no i have to like i have to do this yeah
i think that not now
not yet but um
you're doing exactly what you should be
doing but i think eventually you'll just
be like oh yeah i'm just gonna like
do this on my terms and just like
beyonce that shit and just like drop
a show at midnight and then you don't
hear from me for a year mm-hmm
yeah but i am sorry i just like came on
your podcast for you to give me advice
for like no i mean i'm not i like this
is like
i don't i have no advice for you like i
feel like you're
know so much more than me because i'm
like an old boomer that's just
shut up doesn't it do you know what i'm
saying no so what is the story about the
comedy connection in boston
oh i my first stand-up show i saw was
you
at the wilbur that's so weird and i
dragged like three of my friends
so i was like a huge fan that's really
funny um
i loved how much shit you talked about
boys
i like really related to that and um
yeah we all went and it was great
that's really funny and weird yeah i
watched like all of whitney
that's so funny i like i love staring at
me like delusional with a sinus
infection
no i know i came i came and like didn't
speak for the first like 30 minutes
um because i was just like like watching
you like live
and be like just a medium yeah uh yeah i
watched
i like watched all of your stuff and was
like a really big fan
it's wildly nice if you did instagram
this is my this would be my plan
you do instagram and you don't literally
phone it in
the way you do now because you're like
you just i could see your adversarial
relationship with it
which is why i love you which is also
why i like it this is why michael
patrick king
hired me uh i mean mainly he said why he
like called me back for a second meeting
for two part girls because
after i left i bombed the meeting so bad
and i left the meeting and i just went i
know you're not gonna hire me
like i i know there's no way i'm gonna
get this job but like
let me know if you want me to come and
do punch-up when you do the round table
that's me at this point yeah we're the
same person i know like
i know i fucking totally ruined this
opportunity for
any of your the people who listen to
this no way there's there's no way to do
it
authenticity is the only way you know
what i'm saying yeah and so
um you'll just learn to see those inner
monologue
like as like i feel like i'm looking
it's like taylor tomlinson it's like i
feel like
it's like taylor and i have this thing
too where i'm just like i used to think
that way and i just want you to get
here faster because i want to save you
time but i probably probably can't
like you'll still have so annoying to
hang out with young people i can't even
imagine
it's it's not it's exhausting but i but
no it's more frustrating because i just
want you to you're hanging out with an
ignorant person i'm like
they're not like i just want you to
enjoy
life faster but i didn't i mean it took
me to like
my dad had to die and i had to like get
my heart destroyed and i had to like
my parents had to have strokes like i
had to get can't like publicly dragged
on the internet
i like i had to have like nothing to
lose and then
i was just like all right well that
didn't work why don't i try this way and
then i went to
12-step programs for 10 years and did
like emdr and hypnosis and all sorts of
shit
so um but yeah i just wa
like i still have the same thoughts you
have i just don't
i look at them um like science fiction
like star wars you know i'm like that
was a crazy thought like i don't take my
thoughts as
feelings aren't facts you know like
feelings aren't facts that was just a
feeling like these are just feelings
yeah i can just make my feeling a fact
so quickly
but it's just like it's why we have
restrained a pen and tongue just don't
say it just don't say it
as soon as you say it now you're
validating it and it becomes so it's
just like
if i have if i want to take an action if
i want to respond to that email or
respond to that text or i gotta pick my
stomach because of a weird text or my
manager called me and i didn't
like wait three days i have to wait
three
days and no email should be longer than
two sentences
really and there's no responding to
something that's like a tricky situation
uh unless i like the same day
if i have to go to sleep because then
i'm gonna be waiting for the response
like i have all these like
we call them bottom lines in program to
like protect yourself from the
after burn spiral i had an idea for text
messages for the iphone
um where they basically would be like an
app for
anxious people where they you have two
categories before you send a text to
someone
and you either put it in like don't
worry category so when you get a text
that's like hi you know it's like not
worried
or it's like i should be scared that's
funny that's right right right right
so you know when it's coming in like if
you should that's really funny
thanks that's what comedians say to each
other
i know we don't laugh i know that's
funny you're used to that though yeah i
like that about you
but um but yeah so it's just like i just
i feel like we were talking about that
okay so
if you made the movie so i remember um
i feel like i'm talking too much um the
when obama his last year in office
um i think i've told this story before
but i feel like we've cut it out because
i'm always so embarrassed about it
that uh i like i i'll tell stories on
the podcast and then cut them because
i'm like i think i told that story
before and they're like no you've cut it
every time
it's like so neurotic but um
uh uh the last year in office um
michelle obama did a phone call with
um show runners where
she it was like it was like ryan murphy
and
like um shawna rhymes and like amy
sherman palladino like all these writers
and we were on like a conference call
with her and she
said um i just want you guys to know
we've found uh
we're now able to link uh the passage of
marriage equality to the show will and
grace
wow because having will and grace like
a lot of people just don't know gay
people like they're just don't have them
in their towns or they
only see five people on their way to
work and they just have not met
a gay couple and having one in your
living room you know every day that it
turned into like oh yeah
i would love for them to jack and
whatever will to get
um married course and she was like so
just
everything you're doing on television
like has an impact you know
like when you cast the dry cleaner to be
asian when you cast the valet to be
mexican
or you know what i'm saying like every
little decision you make
is subconsciously being clocked by
people you know
and so we always stay in writer's rooms
like we're just writers we're not curing
cancer
but like you know so
i just argue that you making a movie
that
connects to people like i mean you've
seen movies that have changed your
life or have just something clicked you
know
yeah like when i saw irreversible i like
it like changed the way that i like
perceived time and like
made me more present like you could do
that with a movie and you're giving back
in a different way you're not just like
throwing cash at a corrupt charity
i guess to think that i could have such
an impact on people that i would
fund my own movie because i think i'm
going to change the world with it
or change you have to change the world
yeah like i made a fucking little movie
that was
like ridiculous and people all like even
like men will be like i understand my
wife so much better thank you i
understand my daughter's so much better
our women will be like
i used to think i was crazy and now i
just i know i'm sense like it's just
like
you will affect people you're just you i
think you still have
or you might have this thing in your
head that you need to get like everyone
no i guess i just like think i need to
like work
for it even though it seems like i'm not
working harder
you work harder than maybe me which is a
wild you're very hard on yourself
you're harder on yourself than other
people are
like people like you and you're like uh
trust me
like do what i mean i you're bullying
yourself a little bit yeah
i i work hard for like what i
get and i don't want to but you're
worried that i need that
process to prove to myself like when
this happens that like no i worked hard
for this yeah but also you know that i
had no industry connections i had no
nothing when i came to this business and
everyone was like oh well
she slept her way to the top yeah so
it's like they said the same thing about
me
right they said i didn't deserve it well
you know you think about like
just because like we have twitter and
all these things now like like
sofia coppola like there's so many
people who like have
you know family members in the industry
and then decided to do that
and they were just like i made a sofia
coppola movie and my name is on it
people would say it was awful
full stop stop sorry
they would they would say it was
terrible and self-indulgent and who
cares and it's a bunch of people in
tokyo dancing in a hotel room where are
the jokes it's not funny
like it's just it's it
it's there's a you have to have like a
feline
enigmatic like i don't want it thing
for people to respect you and i'm just
that i'm not that bitch
i i openly want it i want it
and i'm like hence the advertisements
i'm just saying for the longest time i
was like no i don't want to be sad i'm
like what is this what is this
act like because women aren't allowed to
want things and be ambitious or maybe
men it's unattractive
to like want it all and i kind of was
just like
what why am i why do i feel ashamed
someone else some fucking silicon valley
psychopath date rapist is gonna take all
the money if i don't why don't i just do
it
and like me apologizing i'm just sending
a message to the next generation that
they shouldn't
want things you know what i mean you're
a much better role model than i am
you're but you don't have why would you
be a role model right now you don't do
why don't don't you being authentic is
the al is the
i think way to go and you're just i
would be saying all the same things
at your age um you know what i mean like
this is
this is why this is so many people love
this book because they're going to go
like that's how i think
and i read it and i'm like that's how i
used to think then i saw the octopus
thing and i had a heart attack
because i'm obsessed with octopuses
pusses there's a new documentary no
don't even talk about it no it's good
it's right
in the trailer it's a man who i know my
friends i'm aware
it's really beautiful i'm really into
octopuses and um
uh i mean my table i'll show you
downstairs i have my octopus collection
um now what i have to say something
funny before
i go i don't want this to end because
i'm like fascinated by how
i think the only person that's more
comfortable with silence has been
sebastian
you think i've been silent yeah you're
making me
chatty no i think it's because i you're
really funny and like quick
and it makes it it shrinks me down
whereas if you were being quiet i would
be like
what the fuck is going on like with
these chargers
seriously so you give me permission to
like be quiet and like
yeah is it fun or is it is it like
taking a load off or is it like uh
yeah no you're you've taken control and
i appreciate that
no but no one wants to hear from me they
hear from me every fucking week they
want to hear from you
yeah i'm sorry they've heard guys i
don't have anything for you
it's like you said earlier it's like i
have nothing i literally nothing else
you're just like out
yeah you're like out of things to say
that's so interesting maybe i'm not i
don't know i don't know what the right
thing is
i love it but that's exactly like
anybody that
um says that they do is lying
meghan trainor was funnier on your
podcast than i am
meghan trainor is wildly funny she's
really funny
it was it was i mean i'm shocked when
comedians are funny i like
i was her brain is so fucking fast yeah
i
am so sexist or i'm so um
uh i discriminate against pop stars like
i just i'm like oh they must all be like
pre-packaged and like no i don't know
why
you don't i don't i can you do you not
she's back like i get i guess i just
thought they were all like airheads that
just got their songs written for them
and there and then i listen to her music
and it's all like
like rose joke and like witty yeah i
wouldn't consider her like a vapid pop
star
yeah but i didn't i just i just go pop
star makeup
shoes glitter like i'm sexist like that
it's like before i watched cheer i was
like the cheerleading show i was like
whoa sequins makeup
like i have that internalized misogyny
shit around like makeup
and like prom queenie the girls that are
too feminine
mm-hmm you know yeah i'm embarrassed or
like i
want to be that it's very pink it's just
like the color pink
yeah it's like it's that shit like
i don't know it's not me but you don't
hear songs by pop stars that are like
i hate myself and like i feel unsexy and
like this guy doesn't want to fuck me
and uh no one no rapper's like i'm
number three
jose it's always i would love a rapper
or like a pop star that's like
i'm like just like no one is attracted
to me
i'm like i have like a good amount of
money yeah
like i'm doing fine like
i just got an audi it's never not like
i'm the hottest fucking thing you've
ever seen
and i'm really good at sex and like i'm
pretty good at sex
she comes like most of the time i think
yeah and like i want a poster that's
like i couldn't get my boyfriend hard
last night that's why i love
robin yeah so much fucking awesome
robin's like
i'm in the corner watching you kiss the
hot girl like i'm
yeah like i'm number two mm-hmm like i
know i'm number two
and like that's cool that like that's
why robin's my shit
yeah because she's like the underdog
she's 100
you always want to be the underdog what
do you listen to music-wise um
music's hard for me because genuinely if
i listen to music i can't go to sleep i
get stuck in my head forever
emotional yeah but because you think
about the lyrics are you getting no no
no
it's um it gets stuck in my head yeah
and
oh i won't be able to think and then
it's just in my head until like four in
the morning
it's like a um uh like a ref like you're
like singing it
yeah it's just like repeating in my head
like one line but i i like a lot of
different types of music but i really do
always feel super pretentious when
discussing music
really love it what do you listen to
like the white stripes
i don't know bonnie bear
he's good
like are you like i love jodie mitchell
no i don't i do actually you know really
yes
i don't really never really got it
really yeah
whoa it's like kind of like
i was going the same nails on a
chalkboard but i
i didn't what do you mean it's a little
twangy it's a little
it doesn't feel nice in my ears
you might have the misophonia thing too
i understand that she's like an
incredibly talented person do you like
asmr
do i like it yeah like do you can you
listen to asmr i've never seeked it out
you've never watched asmr i've seen like
fucking w magazines like
and you don't like it
what's to like like what's to dislike
but what's to like she's just like this
person
yeah it's nothing yeah
existential crisis fully
do you ever reach on beaudry yard what
you're leaving here with a lot of books
yeah yeah so yeah you're yeah you're a
chronic yeah this is
this is this is exactly how your brain
should be you just have to
your brain is a wild mustang and you
can't train it you're never is
you're never gonna train it you're gonna
have to get it a corral
you're gonna get it like a four acre
corral and let the mustang be a mustang
yeah do what i mean i'm gonna have my
dad pay for the crowd
that's your shit and the mustang and
that's yours
no one's i don't think about your dad
when i talk to you no offense
no thank you i'm a fan and i don't i
don't think about him
you're thinking about him don't drag me
into that oh
i'm sorry don't drive i'm sorry i wasn't
doing that
it was for them i don't know that i know
you know what i'm saying it's like
so it's like it's like what are the
things that we carry
that we're making people i'm
perpetuating
what are we perpetuating it's such an
odd thing
you're perpetuating the sexism yeah
totally
yeah wait wow i mean i know i am
well because you you brought it up again
oh yeah yeah
yeah because i think that i'm always so
afraid
like i had a journalist accuse me of
being sexist
and it is it hit me in a way that is
like
i never recovered like i never recovered
i'm always playing defense
also if i'm late because of traffic
um i'll send a picture of the traffic
because i think that the person i'm
sending it to thinks i'm lying
i am like sorry traffic's crazy and i'll
send a photo of the traffic because that
that's how bad
that and they're like okay i'm friends
with a pathological liar
and once they told me they were in the
hospital so they couldn't hang out
and i literally was like send me a
picture of the hospital oh no
then they did then they were in the
hospital
so who's the liar now this
is a yeah it's a it's a change i'll
never question anyone and they'll be
like i
literally like a a dog talk to me last
night
they did yeah because you want to yeah i
think we're also conflict avoidant
unless it's with ourselves oh yeah like
i'd rather just like go in
like the bad improv of like i'd rather
just go yeah but me avoiding conflicts
which i'm constantly doing just gets me
into more
conflicts obviously yeah but i think
there's something like
in this there's something comfortable
about the struggle
yeah like i go on vacation and i'm just
miserable
i was so scared once i like this is like
a conflict that you avoid and then you
get into another conflict is that you
i like once um my friend dm'd like
something you know when your friend dms
you something that they're making fun of
oh and then you're so scared of getting
hacked that you
you're like oh i'm gonna leave this
damned to the i i'll make fun of
someone's instagram oh no i can't dm it
to the person i'm making fun of yeah so
everyone does that because it's a
i've got it to like a powerful but it's
a product of technologies we're just
like not acclimated to yet
yet and our brains don't like process it
so anyways i was so scared of my dms
getting hacked so i refused to like make
fun of them on dm
and then i went to go text them instead
so our conversation would be private
in our text and then i texted it to the
person so like something i was avoiding
you know out of anxiety i ended up
putting
myself in a situation that was like and
then the last so much worse why do i
have to
oh i did a i did a benton
it was like a six-hour saga there was
someone on twitter
that's like a twitter person that we
made fun of like in a video
reading their like apology
or like their statement about something
making fun of them
and sent it to them and as soon as i
realized it was sending
i threw my phone to the place in my
backyard that there's no wi-fi like
across a wall
yeah and then i ran upstairs and called
this like i.t person from my phone uh
you can't unsend a text which is a wild
i got in trouble for saying that on
election day i was like hey this might
not be the time to address this but can
we work on sending texts or something
like i feel like this is the issue of
the day or something yeah because you
can't and
and then we had to go he had to like go
into my icloud and then send it it was
like a nightmare but they could do that
no the person luckily had a samsung or
the file was too big
but it still came up with the little
minus sign
and i deleted it and the person never
got it
but that's what's so sad about all these
things like chris evans like with his
you know posting his dick by accident
yeah it's just like we don't know
how it works and instead of like
publicly humiliating someone
for a mistake that like any of us could
be i don't know if any of us could have
made that mistake but yeah
probably a lot of us it's just like so
fucked up
people care that much like i think
people like i think
people are more forgiving than we are i
think most people
don't care like when i went to um i was
like really surprised that like a bunch
of like
influencers didn't start posting their
tits and being like hashtag justice for
chris evans i don't know i thought that
was a really good opportunity
but it was like no one knows who chris
evans is they're like that's the guy
from
superman who's captain america whatever
exactly everyone knows who he is and now
everyone
knows his dick and that's going to go
everyone does my aunt in virginia have
you guys did you guys see chris evans
yeah they did but that's not
everyone you know what i'm saying it's
like it's like no one can we all know
we've all seen it it could
like it's fine okay
yeah we are exactly that's how we should
be there was a p-tape
associated with our president what we
haven't talked about in three years
we're talking about it right now
i'm just saying like everyone remembers
the pizza no one really is
they're not thinking about it all the
time but it's associated yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's the assistant
isn't harmed no he's fine
yeah and he made it into a good cause
the point is i don't
know that we're all susceptible to these
yeah
but humiliation yours happened though
though you should be like
the shoe dropped dude you had yours
don't you think
i fucking hope so if that wasn't
it i don't think i think you're like out
of the woods
but i think you're like like um i don't
know i felt like this whole book release
i was like
this is like yeah i know because p the
clickbaits it's how they make money it
was just like pete davidson
was like i don't even know why pete
davidson's so famous it's such a
interesting
thing you know um but yeah i was just
like
well like yeah yeah it's the same for me
it's like why
is anyone seeing my name and it's like
oh because blank and then
yeah yeah yeah but yeah i don't know
maybe because i'm a girl and i'd like
i'm interested in what a 26 year old's
view on the world is right like that's
my personal preference it's like oh what
the fuck are they going through like are
they going through the same shit
you know like yeah um but uh
i just think that like there's this um
there's this charity i work with called
beagle freedom project that is not a
scam
if you want to donate your money to them
it's the beagles um are the most tested
on
animals and labs because they're the
most forgiving breed
i know i know i know i
i know i'm so sorry so they like put you
know
shit in their eyes and okay and they're
in a crate and they're in a crate
and and once you see it like it becomes
it's become my whole life since you know
you see one image and you're like
so we get them out um uh beagle freedom
gets them out of the
and they're in a crate for like eight
years they're in a thing
and they just go in circles and then we
release them
they come from korea and universities a
lot of universities test on fucking dogs
like no one talks about it
um and they walk we put them on grass
for the first time
you know they've got like numbers
tattooed on their ears and there's these
lab dogs that are all you know a little
janky
and they go out on the grass and they
like run back into the crate
like it's just like and we're like what
are you doing why don't you and then
they'll go out on the grass and they'll
find a corner and then they'll just go
in circles in the corner
and you're just like why would run out
on the grat like
and then there's a moment where you see
them realize and it's like
i'll send you a youtube video you'll cry
forever okay yeah you'll cry forever
yeah but it's like i think that a lot of
times we
when are we in that moment where we're
like still
operating as if we're in old
circumstances
like like i'm looking at you like you're
like this beagle that like came out of
the cage and you're just like
i know what the kate it's like the devil
you know i know what the cage is
and like out here everyone's like come
on like
go play everyone's like we've all been
humiliated
yeah everyone's just like or like lucky
you that yours is over
like ours is on the way you know what i
mean
so it's it's it's like um please don't
make sounds on this
uh please don't bang on the podcast
table uh for your
uh little neurons um so like that
i say that as someone that thought i
think a lot like you
for a really long time you know
i know you want me to talk right now no
i'm trying i'm fascinated by how
you you don't blab when you're when it's
quiet i do
it must be a nightmare i'm hungry oh
okay good what do you eat
why do you think i'm a nightmare today i
am but because you just like like
stare if you just stare at a man and
don't laugh at his jokes so
they'll kill like i think actually some
a man's gonna kill you for not laughing
that's actually what's gonna happen to
you
anything else
was i okay like was this fine i mean i'm
really psyched you are i feel like it
started off a little
weird he's just cut like the first i was
a little weird in the beginning no
i was i've honestly talked to this about
with
leona and everything but like i have a
tendency sometimes i have like two paths
i can take
one is like be funny and that's like so
easy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's so big and you always hate
yourself then everyone would say she's
trying too hard and you would leave here
feeling
so i feel like we're like in bed hanging
out
yeah like if you left here
like with the having tap dance the whole
time you would
be so like consumed but instead of
choosing that path there's like i
literally have the choice of like being
funny or like being dark and like
like being quiet and i feel like i did
that by accident for like but that's
like
oddly i never i hate saying this
especially to women but that's like the
braver choice
sincere is the new funny sincere's new
funny respect is the new famous
dude i mean i'm telling you vulnerable
is a new one
funny like i can go on youtube and watch
someone jump in and pull with the water
in it like i can just watch fun that's
my
that's my sense of humor yeah i can go
watch molokov whenever i want
uh but uh like funny is like
yeah anyway i mean i hope we literally
talked about anything that like because
that's also it's like
i was talking to tim dillon about this
last night of like this pandemic kind of
broke comedy or the internet kind of
broke comedy because we realized that
comedians aren't the only people that
are funny like
some of the funniest memes it's like by
some teenager in pensacola florida and
you're like
people are funny yeah like people are
comedians aren't the only people that
are funny like when i go to like
weddings of like my high school friends
i'm like dude this person is so much fun
this guy from accounting like is so
funny like you are so much funnier than
most and you're like a better person
because you're like not even trying to
do it
and you're just like doing it for the
love of the game yeah you're doing it
for 10 people you're just like a funny
person you're not trying to capitalize
on that demanding that everybody shut up
for an hour
and then like how dare you give me notes
on my phone like it's just like
it's just like oh i know i just truly
want to make people laugh yeah there's
no strength i don't need like a website
for it mm-hmm
they're just like no i'm just wanting to
give you a little joy do it in your day
yeah so it's like i feel like
you know with like twitter instagram and
memes and stuff it's like
to listen to a podcast it's just like
joke is like a little bit
like what i i lo my favorite podcast is
listening to bill burr
just trying to figure out how to plug in
his computer it's so soothing
it's him just being like ah fucking i
have the wrong charger fuck and it's
just like
just like trying his daughter walks in
and he's like honey i'm working
anyway i can't say anything i want to
say because you're here like it's just
like
so soothing to me because if you're
being funny then the listener now has to
judge how well you're doing
and they have to work then they have to
go like ah that wasn't funny that was
funny
yeah if you don't try you're just
hanging out together do i mean
like what can they get us on yeah you'll
be surprised
no wait you'll find if you look for it
you'll find it yeah
you'll find what you're looking for but
also like people i said this to taylor
tomlinson once because
when she started getting really
successful she was like people don't
like me i'm like they didn't like you
before
yeah they just didn't know for a
different reason yeah they wouldn't have
liked if you didn't have a netflix
special they wouldn't like the same
people that don't like you
for being successful liked you when you
weren't you know
like it's just like you can't there's
always going to be people that need to
judge and
dislike you for their own anesthetic
purposes think about when you don't like
someone
or like when you judge someone you're
just like why did i do that i'm so dumb
yeah it's also harder on them you know
when you like criticize someone or
gossip about someone then you feel like
shit after
whenever someone talks shit about me now
i'm like oh i feel so bad for you now
that you have to feel bad
for beating up on someone that's already
been dragged publicly for 10 years
like it's just like hope that worked
like i
like wish them the best you're like
stunning it's kind of crazy
that's really wild that you just said
that because i have snot no you're
dipping down
like i look like a doll that's very
sweet that's the doll
she's in the corner i know all about her
um but no
i think the same thing about you but i
don't want to over compliment you
because i know it's going to make you
like suicidal
um but i also have snot dripping down my
face speaking you know
is infection so i've been like white
like a crackhead
no you look amazing that's very nice
thank you that's very charming
really pretty in person i agree
i'm not going to disagree with you
because then i'm an asshole yeah
um i remember ron funches said once um
i had posted a picture of me and him
like it was like a selfie or something
of us in like new york and i posted it
and i have like a crooked front tooth
that i've done invisalign on a bunch of
times but i just can't like
kick it and then a lot of photos on my
carpets it looks like i'm like missing a
tooth
it's i know it's it's
minut it's so small but to me it's giant
and i put in the photo like oh me and
ron funch is in the gym
and here's me in the best angle of my
crooked tooth
and he called me
a couple hours later and was like hey
like
i would want to know this and i'm like
don't shoot the messenger but like
two of my girlfriends just unfollowed
you because
they're like think you're pretty and you
insulting your appearance is like well
then
you know what i mean i was just saying
that like because i have an essay in
hero about how i like
don't think i'm like attractive and it's
like what it is
you're the megan fox of your day that's
ridiculous i know
that's ridiculous but it is like your
experience like this is like
what yeah yeah yeah how i feel yeah but
feelings are facts
you just my thing is just like don't be
a climate
like be don't you're a flat earther like
if you don't think you're pretty like
that's
you're also the earth is flat also like
you know what i mean just get into this
math it's you also
you're not you don't get to decide
because you're not your consumer
you don't get to decide if you're pretty
i that's my decision to make
so if you think i'm pretty that's your
truth i don't like
it's not in my business that is my truth
yeah yeah
so yeah delete anything that
[Laughter]
you know it's talking like that are you
liking a total shame spiral
yeah i always end these very awkwardly
is there anything else you want to do or
say or do you want to just redo it
tomorrow
let's just redo it is there anything i
say like that's the one that got all
viral
do you like do you like to eat an
entire meal and then get fucked like uh
i just like don't understand the
controversy
like truly if you can find me someone
who can eat an
entire huge meal and then
enjoy getting fucked like i will like
submit
to the criticism i don't know what the
criticism is
i if it's that i don't know what sex or
like food is like i don't get it
like they literally i think i died
definitely
if i know i'm having sex i i like won't
have dinner
it's not even i won't have dinner so
that i'm not going to eat until i feel
sick which is like what i don't usually
have a lasagna
i'm not going to stuff myself to the
brim yes because guys
are so into butts now too that it's like
you know
like there's gonna be a finger or
something and i'm like i
i have to make sure my intestines are
like clear
cleared out smoothie a smoothie at like
4 30 and then like i'll pick us out okay
here's a question
if you eat a huge meal would you want to
exercise after
well i have i used to be an exerciser
wreck sick i would eat and then work out
but that was just me
because i that was my eating disorder
would you like to jump up and down
no no it's no it's it's seven minutes
you're right would you like to do
jumping jabs you got
too much and you deserved it and people
don't like it
why not feel bad for them that they care
because it's just like i
i know you guys are too full to fuck
it's like
like like you're trying to embarrass me
but it's like i know
that you are yeah but it's like you're
you're
like a tory amos you're like a fucking
fiona apple like you're like a fucking
firestarter you're a provocateur like
you can't
you you you know it's taken me so long
to accept this about myself but you
can't have it both ways you can't be an
original
thinker that says shit that no one has
the balls to say
and then expect everyone to not be
shocked like so what we do we shock
people and then when we shock them we're
like what are you so shocked about
i shocked people for a living yeah i did
my job and you're you're
like wouldn't you rather that but can
you imagine being shocked by that how
about this how about people going
uh heard this before uh too full of fuck
i talk about that all the time
the reason you're special is you say the
shit nobody says and this is just like
a tax it's just like a little bit of tax
that you have to pay
this is that you're in the pocket you're
you're getting the exact reaction you
should get
for the trajectory you want
you know what i'm saying fuck yeah thank
you
like if no one was shocked you would be
boring as fuck
and everyone no one would buy the book
because there'd be nothing in here that
was gonna
say something i've never heard before
am i wrong you ha you have to like
accept the uh shrapnel
that comes with being
outspoken and like
being shocking is that you're going to
shock some people and it's good
yeah and it's not real controversy
it's just people that are addicted to
self-righteous indignation and like let
them have it
they're just they're just helping you
sell your book they're like they're your
publicists they're helping you
thank you thank you so much yeah like
ten more people bought my book because
you tweeted that you hated it thank you
so bunch of people just google me just
like think take the compliment and move
on
um yeah thank you for pretending like
you like
like to eat an entire bowl of pasta
no it's just like i can't i mean
i think it's that's someone that's you
know when you're like
arguing with someone like when a guy's
like you're being a bitch i'm like did
you just call me a bitch like no i said
you were being a bitch it's like you got
me on a formality
like you just want to fight that's
someone that agrees with you but they
just want the fight
yeah you know what i'm saying do you see
when guys like in bars just start
fighting each other
i also think it's sports one way when
sports went away
everyone's need to fucking watch people
to fight and cheer people on and fuck
you and you suck like that there was
like this huge void left and then
everybody had to just like go on the
internet and just do sports on the
internet
like sports on twitter yeah love twitter
sports well yeah because it's like we're
wrong i mean it's like the roman
coliseum it's like we used to
humans used to go watch people get torn
apart by
lions slowly for hours
and they'd pay money they'd go to the
town square and watch people be hanged
like we have a very deep need to watch
people be humiliated
yeah well it worked everyone
congratulations
um okay don't ride elephants do all the
things that you're supposed to do
we're gonna both go uh spiral and um
maybe this episode will air maybe
[Laughter]
thank you guys love you live to peace
[Music]
[Applause]